[Musique]
nous savons que ce n'est pas un beau match que nous
jouons contre un grand public et
aussi l'équipe est très bonne, celle
des Géants d'Afrique donc ça ne va pas
être un créneau sympa pour nous mais quoi qu'il en soit, je
pense que nous sommes préparés et  nous allons
faire de notre mieux
[Musique]
Je pense que nous avons beaucoup appris parce que
nous étions là-bas au Gabon et nous avons joué
contre des équipes plus grandes aussi donc je pense que nous
avons acquis un peu plus d'
expérience et nous sommes  en espérant que cette
fois-ci sera différente et que
nous ferons de notre
mieux et que nous entrerons dans l'histoire, Maxima sera fière de
rendre tout le monde heureux au Zimbabwe
[Musique]